SIERRA: Hello! So, If you listen to WIM you
know we talk a lot about China. Before we
started today, I wanted to let you guys know
about a new infoguide from CFR fellows Joshua
Kurlantzick and Yenjong Hwong. It’s called
“China’s Approach to Global Governance”.
It takes a deep, visually rich dive into China’s
history, and its ambitious rise on the global
stage. Check it out on CFR.org. Thanks!
Politics 101: Ladies and gentlemen, nothing
is more important in our history.
WHTV: How they wish to be judged by history.
Washington Post: The stock market reached
yet another all time high today in history.
Guardian: The longest stretch of job creation
in our history.
CBS: The history of the United States.
HAASS: History is not a cookbook. It doesn't
give you exact recipes to understand the present
or predictive future. But what it does is
give you context, it gives you comparisons,
it gives you perspective. History doesn't
repeat itself. But to use the old saw it does
rhyme.
GORDON-REED: Things that may seem perplexing
to you, have their roots in things that happened
in the past. It would be as if you were trying
to tell your story to someone, but you didn't
know where you were born. You didn't know
who your parents were. You didn't have any
memories of things that had happened when
you were a child. History consists of, of
things in the past that have had a bearing
on the present that you might wanna know.
That help you explain why you're in the situation
you're in, why we are in a situation in a
given society.
MACMILLAN: We need perspective in history.
Sometimes things that look very important
at the time turn out not to be that important.
And sometimes things that look very unimportant
turn out to be very important. History doesn't
reveal itself right away. And we need to think
about it. We need to look at the evidence,
we need to interpret it.
Global News: Now, as the COVID 19 pandemic
continues to grow, so are the parallels being
drawn between it and another deadly virus
that struck the globe more than a century
ago.
CBS: The pandemic of 1918.
Al Jazeera: From the international monetary
fund, a stark warning.
ITV News: It is the worst crisis since the
Great Depression.
BBC: The Great Depression almost a century
ago.
CNBC: The killing of George Floyd has sparked
nationwide protests, demanding an end to police
brutality.
FOX: Nascar is banning the confederate battle
flag.
ABC: We move on now to the showdowns across
America, protestors toppling statues and monuments
of confederate leaders and slave owners.
CBS: [Protest Sounds]
SIERRA: There’s no doubt about it. We’re
in a situation right now. The things we’re
experiencing everyday just feel historic.It’s
not just a pandemic, not just a global economic
recession, and not just an anti-racism protest
movement that spread across the globe. But
dozens of world events that give a sense of
things changing -perhaps even falling apart.
There’s an old saying that those who don’t
understand history may be doomed to repeat
it. But, there’s also a lesser known saying
that those who don’t know history, lose
out on the opportunity to repeat the things
that worked. So we went out and found three
historians to try to help us understand what
history is for, and to explain what the past
can tell us about the current moment.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It
Matters. Today, does history matter? And what
type of history are we in right now?
SIERRA: It feels like right now history is
back. You know, it's been a long break for
a lot of people, young people see themselves
going through things that, you know, they
only imagine their grandparents going through,
a quarantine, a, a potential economic depression.
So, what do you think history can tell us
about right now, about our current moment?
MACMILLAN: I think what history can tell us
about our current moment is that, you know,
we are part of the human race, and we shouldn't
expect ... Although, I suppose we've got used
to expecting that everything's going to go
smoothly for us, and we don't need to look
backwards.
SIERRA: This is Margaret MacMillan, a leading
historian and professor of history at Oxford
University. Her books have received the Hessell-Tiltman
Prize for History and the Samuel Johnson Prize,
among others.
MACMILLAN: I think history reminds us that
combinations of circumstances, a sudden pandemic,
a sudden depression can throw all our assumptions
up in the air. And I think we're going through
this now, but I think what history will tell
us, and it can be reassuring, is that sooner
or later we do tend to get out of these things.
Sooner or later the Great Depression ended,
and the world got back onto a more even keel.
So, we shouldn't despair, to remember that
humanity has been through many crises in its
long history, and has managed somehow to deal
with them and move on. But I think what history
can also tell us is the good ways, and bad
ways of dealing with crises, and when you
come out of a crisis, good ways and bad ways
of learning from it.
HAASS: Generations are often defined by a
common experience that gives a cohort of people
an identity. So, we talk about maybe the civil
rights generation, or the Vietnam generation,
or now it will probably be something about
the pandemic. Before that, might be 9/11,
might be Iraq. Maybe Afghanistan. Could be
for some the financial crisis.
SIERRA: This is Richard Haass, president of
the Council on Foreign relations, and, it
should be noted, my boss. But we didn’t
talk to him just because of that. Richard
has been on the front lines of history advising
President George H W Bush, running policy
planning for the State Department, and negotiating
peace in Northern Ireland as a special envoy.
He also has a new book out that contains a
lot of history, called The World: A Brief
Introduction.
HAASS: For my father, who was born in 1917,
it was the Depression. And he had me read
a book, when I was, came of age, called the
Invisible Scar. He said, "If you want to understand
me and my generation, you have to read this
book the Invisible Scar. Because this tells
you about how all of us who went through the
Depression, and in his case collected milk
bottles so they would have enough to eat.
You have, in order to understand me now, you
have to understand what I went through with
a lot of others." And I, uh, that, that had
an impression on me.
SIERRA: So, I mean, the idea there is that
learning history helps you sort of escape
the bias of your own generation and go wider
and understand other ones.
HAASS: Absolutely. Learning history gives
you a much broader, take I think. Because
all of us, by definition, have narrower experiences.
We're, limited by what we've read, what we've
studied, what we've personally experienced,
by our age. So you know, none of us can travel
back to ancient times, much less, 50, 60,
years ago. We weren't there. But what, what
happened then and there might have relevance
for now. What reading history gives you the
opportunity to do is to get into your time
machine. It's to go back and see for yourself.
You can then take what you've seen through
the words or pictures of others. And then
that forms part of your mental construct,
almost your filter to change images through
which you look at. For example, the present,
or some slice of the present, that you're
trying to better understand. It gives you
a different appreciation, a different perspective
on your own life. And also it helps you better
understand different generations.
SIERRA: What periods of history have you been
thinking about as you consider the current
moment?
GORDON-REED: Well, this is a really interesting
moment because we have all of these things
together.We have tremendous partisan conflict,
polarization in society. And of course, that
makes me think of the 1850s before we get
to the Civil War. We're hoping it's not that
bad.
SIERRA: This is Annette Gordon-Reed, professor
of both law and history at Harvard, and the
recipient of the Pulitzer prize. She’s best
known for ground-breaking work on Thomas Jefferson
that revealed his parentage of children with
an enslaved woman, Sally Hemmings.
GORDON-REED: You have the Spanish flu in the
beginning of the 1920s. And you have the Depression.
And all these things are happening together.
This is strange. This is a very, very, singular
moment. There are moments in history, there
are these sort of punctuation points that
come along and they bring about change, as
we seem to be, in that moment now. So, I think
I would have to combine eras. There's no one
time that makes me think of all of these things
together. Someone was joking on Twitter a
couple of weeks ago that 2020 will be like
its own discipline. I mean, historians will
be able to say, "I'm a specialist in April
through June." Or whatever. Because, so much
has taken place in the last, you know, two
or three weeks. It’s different than it was
three months ago. We've forgotten about the
coronavirus. It hasn't forgotten us. It's
still there, but we've moved on to thinking
now about this whole question of police and
race and inequality in the United States.
There are bits and pieces of different eras,
but all of this together. And the thing that
makes this different too from any other era
is the existence of social media. In which
people are connected in ways that even in
the past eras that seem like this are very,
very different. I mean, the news cycle. We
used to talk it, about it being fast because
of cable news, the 24 hour. It's like-
SIERRA: Right.
GORDON-REED: 24 seconds. I mean - 24-minute
cycles. A story can be born and grow up and
die in, in a matter of hours. We're in a brave
new world with all of this.
SIERRA: So what do you think history can tell
us about this current moment?
HAASS: Well, it's an important question. And
it's one I'm wrestling with. I recently wrote
a piece for our magazine, Foreign Affairs,
where I argued that what we were likely to
see was not a turning point in history, but
history's acceleration. That essentially all
the trends that were visible before this:
the worsening, say, of US-Chinese relations,
the weakening of the European, project. And
we can, we can go around the world. A lot
of weak states, potentially failed states.
I thought all of those would be present now
or in the future. But in spades. Even more.
That this would intensify or accelerate history.
And we'll see whether I'm right. What also
worries me, and I think I ended the piece
with this, is the historical parallels. Where
would this leave the world? And there were
some people out there in the conversation
saying, "Oh, this is terrible. But there's
going to be a silver lining. We're all going
to learn the lesson of, uh, the futility of,
uh, ignoring global challenges like pandemics
or climate change or what have you and we're
going to strengthen all of our global institutions."
And I shrug my shoulders and go, "Maybe."
Now that did happen once in modern history.
Which was right after World War II. You had
an extraordinary period of institution building,
alliances through the World Bank, the IMF,
the UN. And it set the stage for 70, 75 years
of really unprecedented peace, prosperity,
uh, democratic development.
SIERRA: The post WWII era was exceptional,
and among historians it seems to be the go-to
choice for an optimistic precedent for our
current, chaotic times. Then, too, it felt
like the world had fallen apart, that the
old way of doing things was gone. Look, of
course not everything was perfect. But the
world stepped up to the plate. Led by the
United States, a series of structural changes
brought about increasing prosperity and relative
global peace.
MACMILLAN: We know why the second World War
broke out. There's very little debate about
its origins, and it broke out because of extremism.
It broke out because you had highly nationalistic
governments motivated by a variety of ideologies
who want to extend their power, and, and conquer
others. And it was a catastrophe for the world.
But out of it came something I think much
better. I mean, I think those who, who led
the allies to victory in the second World
War recognized that they needed to build a
different sort of international order, and,
and it was hoped to avoid a third World War.A
lot of people felt that if there was a third
World War that there would be very little
left of human civilization. So, they were
acting I think under a tremendous sense of
urgency. And what they did is try and avoid
the mistakes of the 1930s. And so, Roosevelt
took the lead in setting up the United Nations.
So, I think we did learn, and our leaders
did learn from the second World War. And in
Europe you saw national leaders recognizing
that Europe could not go through another World
War if it was to survive in any shape or form.
And so, you had European leaders from different
countries extraordinarily from France and
Germany, for example, coming together after
the second World War and saying we need to
set up some sort of supranational organization
which will overcome the poisonous nationalisms,
which have so nearly destroyed Europe and,
and encouraged us to work together. And that
of course was the origins of the European
Union. And so, I think lessons were learnt,
and real change was made after the second
World War. And real change was made domestically
as well. I mean, a number of governments recognized
that there were deep inequalities in their
societies, and they had to do something about
it. And so, you've got a raft of social welfare
measures of free education, of support for
change in society, which really made a difference.
And you could see it playing out through the
1950s and 1960s.
SIERRA: It can be all too easy to forget history,
and to think things have always been the way
they are now. In the U.S. for example, we’ve
become so used to a gridlocked congress and
partisan conflict, that the idea of two nations
- like Germany and France - working together
just a few years after facing off in a bloody
war - seems like a fairy tale. But it can
happen. And it did.
MACMILLAN: The trouble is that as great catastrophes
fade into the past, we tend to forget why
we wanted the changes we wanted. And we tend
to forget why we thought it was so important
to have international organizations, and to
have domestic reform, and to try and build
more equal and just societies. And that I
think is a bit what's happened to us in the,
in the last decades. We've forgotten why we
needed some of those institutions, and perhaps
we're going to remember again why we do need
them.
HAASS: It was probably the most, by far, most
creative period of American foreign policy
in the modern era. So some were saying, "Well,
that's the parallel." And I hear that and
I go, "From your mouth to God's ear. But unlikely."
And if you look at all the, the differences
between then and now-I'm struck more by the
differences than the similarities. The only
similarities we, we've come out of something
terrible. That was World War II. Now it was,
will be the pandemic. To me, the parallels
are much more after World War I.
SIERRA: The era after World War I, and particularly
the Great Depression of the 1930s, shows that
global crises don’t automatically lead to
cooperation and improvements.
HAASS: Again you're coming out of something
terrible. But you, how do you, United States,
that was distracted, essentially was, uh,
becoming more, uh, isolationist. You had a
lot of dark forces in the world. Uh, opposition
to immigration. A lot of opposition to, to
free trade. Which led to a heavy rise in protectionism.
And again, I'm not saying now that the situation
will inexorably lead from where it was after
World War I for two decades that led us to
World War II. So I'm not saying-
SIERRA: Oh good.
HAASS: Yes. Uh, as dark as I am, I'm not that
dark. But history provides a warning here.
MACMILLAN: There was a lot of talk that perhaps
democracy had failed because the democracies
didn't seem to be able to cope with mass unemployment,
and, and the terrific economic downturn, and
nor did capitalism seem to be working. And
so, I think there was a real sense that the
pillars of what we felt were Western liberal
societies were crumbling, and nobody knew
what was going to take their place, which
is why of course things like Bolshevism, the
type of, of communism that, that grew up in,
in Russia, that then the Soviet Union, and
the various varieties of fascism, from Italian
fascism to, to Nazism in Germany seemed so
attractive because they seemed to be solving
the problems of mass unemployment, deep divisions
in society. And so, it was a time in which
there seemed to be no clear solution, but
a tremendous loss of faith in existing institutions,
which drove in many countries, people towards
the extremes to the right and the left with,
with really dangerous consequences.
SIERRA: There are uncomfortable parallels
here with our own time. The United States
has retreated from several international agreements
and institutions, including, potentially,
the World Health Organization. The UK has
left the European Union. It’s hard to look
at the news and say that the world is doing
a good job of solving problems together.
So, the idea there is that having a strong
understanding of that period might protect
us now from similar temptations.
MACMILLAN: Well, I think what that period
shows is that you shouldn't go for simple
solutions. I mean, leaders will come along
who say, "Look, it's all very clear. I can
get you all back to work. It's all gonna be
fine. Don't worry. I have a solution." And
that I think we now know is very dangerous
indeed. I don't trust the leaders who offer
very simple solutions to very complicated
problems.
SIERRA: Right. I mean, people love easy answers.
MACMILLAN: We love easy answers and I think
we're seeing it today. You know, we're seeing
a proliferation of conspiracy theories, and
it's a natural human instinct. You know, when
something goes badly wrong, we want someone
to blame, and we like to think there's a cause,
because at least if you can find who's to
blame, and there's a cause you have some hope
of, of dealing with it. But it's a misguided
attempt I think because you know, in something
like this, the, the pandemic or in something
like the Great Depression, there is no single
cause, and there certainly is no single group
to blame. And I think chasing after conspiracy
theories doesn't help us think constructively
about what we need to do. We shouldn't be
looking for blame at this stage, we should
be looking for what we can do, and how we
can get out of this present situation.
SIERRA: Do you think that democracy could
be at risk once again?
MACMILLAN: It depends, I think, very much
on the society, but yes, I think democracy
is clearly at risk in certain countries. In
Hungary, Viktor Orban, the president, has
used the opportunity to give himself power
to rule by decree. In Brazil, I think Bolsonaro
is, is undermining democracies, is, is not
using a democratic means, not, not following
the rules at all. In India, I think. In Turkey
I think we see pre- the press being attacked.
We see civil rights being, being abused. And
so yes, I think people do use the opportunity,
but in other countries I think we see democracy
is actually functioning very well. We see
that in Germany, Angela Merkel has absolutely
managed to bring along the German people,
and I think German democracy will come stronger
out of it because it has actually been very
successful in dealing with the epidemic. But
I think around the world there, there is going
to be a real sort of testing of different
kinds of government. And we will have to see
which come out better. But I'm confident that
democracy will show itself in the long run
to be capable of dealing with such challenges
more effectively on the whole than authoritarian
governments.
SIERRA: OK, so, we have two very different
examples of what can happen when the world
feels like it has come apart. In the case
of the period after World War II, people came
together. Huge structural changes were put
into place, and things changed for the better.
In the case of the 1930s and the Great Depression,
the opposite unfolded. Nations turned inward,
and away from democracy, minorities were scapegoated,
and catastrophe ensued. As historians grapple
to understand what direction we’re headed
in now, one surprising development might provide
a clue: the rapid change in public opinion
about racial justice in the United States.
MACMILLAN: I wouldn't have expected this a
couple of years ago, but I think what's happened
is possibly the pandemic, possibly the failures
of, of the Trump administration to deal with
it, and other issues and worries about immigration,
have somehow crystallized and come together
with the killing of George Floyd to make people
say that there is something we really need
to change about our own society. And it seems
to me that there is a willingness on the part
of, of Americans. I mean, there were always
people who want change, but it seems to me
now there's a much more widespread feeling
that, you know, we really do need to make
change. And I'm certainly noticing it here
in the United Kingdom as well.
SIERRA: A lot of journalists and historians
of the civil rights movement have been noting
that, you know, we've seen scenarios similar
to this before, several times, since the beginning
of the 20th century. And there's debate about
whether or not this instance of unrest is
any different, you know? Whether it will succeed
where others failed. I mean, what do you say
to the idea that history is repeating itself
here?
MACMILLAN: Well, I would say history never
repeats itself entirely because things have
changed, the context has changed. And I think
with anything like civil rights, what tends
to happen is you make progress as a society
and then, and then there is backsliding or,
or moving away from that progress. So it's,
it's not an unbroken march towards a better
society. I don't think history ever, ever
works like that. But it may be too soon to
tell, historians never like to try and judge
their own times when things are happening
right away, but my sense is that there is
more widespread support for significant change
in American society and in some other societies
than there was in the 1960s. I mean, I think
we have to remember in the 1960s, the United
States was very divided about how much change
it wanted. And Richard Nixon got into office
in the election of, of, of 1968, partly because
he talked about appealing to a silent majority
who didn't like all the sorts of changes that
were going on. It seems to me there is a more
widespread movement which goes across, not
just the cities. I mean, it's, you know, there
are demonstrations in small towns. Um, there
are demonstrations in places where you wouldn't
expect to see them in support of George Floyd
and, and demonstrations critical of the police
in places you wouldn't expect to see. So it
seems to me that possibly now we're seeing
something that really is a democratic and,
and movement supported at the grass roots.
GORDON-REED: Oh yes. Uh, this is, uh, a punctuation
point that I was talking about. I referred
to before, a moment when people kinda stop
and say, "Wait a minute, we have to do things
differently." And that has been sort of a
lightning fast change from the notion that
you have to support the police unquestioningly.
It's not like just supporting the, the police,
but without question. To now saying, "Yeah,
we have to, to a degree, but we also have
to start thinking about the right balance
between police power and citizen power." And
yeah, I mean, the majorities now are, are
clear that Americans are ready for some different
way of, of policing and basically determining
how that, that relationship, police to citizen
relationship will, will go forward. And that's,
that's new.
HAASS: Again, history doesn't necessarily
repeat itself. There is the potential for
change. And in areas where reform is called
for you hope not only is there the potential
for change, but you hope that potential is
realized.
SIERRA: So, it's safe for me to just say,
"We're living in a historic moment." You think
I'm good on that?
HAASS: I think you're really good on that.
I actually feel we are living in history.
Uh, it's a phrase I like to use. I feel it
domestically for the reasons we're talking
about, from the pandemic to the protests in
the wake of the killing of George Floyd, the
scale of the unemployment. But I actually
feel we're also living in history internationally.
This is the Council on Foreign Relations.
And I look at China's rise. I looked at the
events in Europe. I look at, uh, the United
States pulling back from any number of international
arrangements. I've got to tell you it doesn't
make me feel good. Most of history to me is
a fairly depressing, uh, undertaking. And
to me, we're seeing the United States, once
again, move in the direction of isolationism.
People are focusing on things internally,
rather than externally. It may be understandable,
but it's still consequential. Uh, I see the
difficulty, not just the United States in
the world, are having with coping with the
pandemic. I see virtually no signs that the
world was contending with climate change.
Terrorists haven't gone away. North Korean,
nuclear weapons and missiles haven't gone
away. Iran hasn't changed it's stripes. We've
got all the refugees and internally displaced.
I could go on and on and it makes for quite
a list and it's, it's not a happy list. So
yeah, I do feel we're living history, but
more than anything else, it's because of the
United States, which for 70, 75 years has
played this outsized role in the world, where
we've essentially abdicated. And it's a bad
combination that you've had this emergence
of, uh, a reemergence of familiar foreign
policy issues. You've got the emergence of
new global issues, and you've got a United
States that is reluctant to act. And this,
this is a toxic combination. And the tragedy
is here we are, after the pandemic began in
Wuhan. You would think the big lesson would
be, that nothing stays local for long. And
this outbreak of disease in this city that
very few had ever heard of would wake us up
to the fact that what happens in the world
matters. To coin a phrase that has something
to do with this, uh, this podcast. And I worry
that people are not drawing the linkages.
SIERRA: Not considering history during a historic
moment is not only bad for governments or
nations or societies, but for individuals
too. Examining past decisions or paths makes
you better equipped to move forward with fresh
ideas, or repeat good ones that worked the
first time around. If nothing else, it makes
you better equipped for an argument, or to
offer up a suggestion at a key time.
HAASS: I'll give you a specific story where
I actually was able to quote, unquote, use
history or apply it. It was, uh, 1991. In
the summer of 1990, Saddam Hussein, Iraq invaded
Kuwait. I was the Chief Middle East Advisor
on the National Security Staff at the White
House. So I was heavily involved in it. Uh,
by the middle of January 1991 we had begun
the counter attack. Essentially Desert Shield
gave way to Desert Storm. Uh, and then towards
the end of February we had transitioned from
just an air war to a ground war and things
were going very fast and going very well.
So by late February the question came up when
do we stop? What do we have to accomplish
before we stop? We had our war aims, which
was to liberate Kuwait. But at that point
things were going so well that there were
certain voices saying, "Maybe we should go
on. Go on to Baghdad. Change the government
and so forth." And I wrote a memo at the time.
Uh, about what happened in the Korean War.
In the 1950, in the Korean War, uh, the United
States, uh, through the United Nations had
gotten involved after the North Korean invasion
of the south. We liberated the south. And
then the question came up, under President
Truman and General MacArthur, whether to stop
there or not. And then the flush of-Uh, tactical
success, we went north of the 30th Parallel.
Went up close to the Chinese border to the
Yalu River. And ignored warnings of what would
happen. Hundreds of thousands of Chinese quote,
unquote volunteers, IE soldiers came in. Two
years later there was a stalemate back at
the 38th Parallel. We had gained nothing.
But we lost another 20,000 lives. And what
I wrote was a memo to President Bush, the
father, about this. About the risk of expanding
war aims in the middle of a war. And I essentially
argued that we should think not just twice
but three times before expanding war aims.
We shouldn't go on to Baghdad. We didn't have
the political backing for it. And here was
a piece of history that said be very, very,
very careful before you do that. Now I can't
sit here and tell you that's what turned the
president around. But, uh, at least for me,
I felt really comfortable in an ability to
bring history to bear on what proved to be
not just an important decision, but I think
history, subsequent history bears out was
the correct decision.
SIERRA: This is, of course, just one example
- the U.S. has not always acted with such
restraint. Careful consideration of history
can help slow things down, and avoid catastrophe.
But that doesn’t mean that it has always
been used for good.
SIERRA: So, do you think that lessons from
history can actually be misused?
MACMILLAN: Oh, I think yes. You have to be
careful with history. The pro- the problem
with history and its lessons is you can basically
find any lesson you want in history. And there's
an awful lot of history there, and there are
an awful lot of lessons. And I think unscrupulous
leaders, or deluded leaders have used history
to try and justify what they're doing. And
it sounds good. You know, if they say to their
people, "Our history tells us that, you know,
such and such has always been our enemy, and
therefore we have to behave in certain ways."
History gives a fake veneer of authority often
to very bad policies. I think the other thing
where history is bad, of course, is when people
remember, and remember historical grievances.
You can get memories that go back, which keep
distrust alive between peoples, and which
can be very unproductive.
GORDON-REED: A bad way of thinking about history
is that, you know, you hear the word revision-
all the time, "Well, that's "... revisionist."
And it's said in a pejorative way, but all
history is revising things. You look at things
and you f- get new information. That's what
history is about. You're always gonna find
things that change the way you think about
stuff. So... I, I would say, you know, this
disinclination to accept new stories grows
out of a mistaken impression that the history
that people wrote 60 years ago was right.
And now you're just coming along and upsetting
that and changing the story. No, you are broadening
the story. You're revising it. Certainly the
rewriting of the story of reconstruction,
in which people painted it as, uh, an era
where black people were ruling over white
people, and black people who couldn't read
or write, or passing ridiculous laws and doing
all kinds of things. That's not true. You
can, if you can tell a history, if you could
make up a story and tell bad history, you
can influence people. So yeah, uh, using the
idea of history can certainly be misused.
If people are trying to do history that is
contextually sound and evidence-based, we're
all gonna make mistakes. That's one thing.
But if to use the mantle of history as, as,
uh, as propaganda, is problematic.
SIERRA: So I know recently, uh, you've written
or over the, over the course of time, you've
written about, um, the recent trend of crowds
tearing down statues of Confederate leaders.
So I'd love to know, uh, you know, what do
you think statues and monuments say about
a culture's relationship to history?
GORDON-REED: Well, it, that's a very, very
good question. Because, people have been relating
it to history. You know, when someone says,
"You're taking down a statue, you're destroying
history." Well, not really. I mean, that's
not how most people learn history. We don't
learn history through statues. We learn history
typically in school, through our own reading
and so forth. You can know about all of these
people, all the statues could disappear and
we would still know (laughs) about, uh, the
important figures of history. But statues
do sort of send a message about a particular
community's values. And what we've been arguing
about is, you know, are there some people
who are unfit, or too problematic, or too
divisive to be the bearer of a message? The
Confederacy's announced purpose was to maintain
white supremacy and African slavery. That
African people, people of African descent,
were meant to be enslaved. And for my values,
or my belief, I, I don't think that that is,
those are ideas that we want to promote in
the public sphere. They lost the war. And
there was a hope that we could move beyond
that with the 13th, 14th, and 15th amendments.
We know it's been a struggle, but the ideal
has been to move beyond the Confederate's
conception of the way the world works.
SIERRA: So, you've taught history for a long
time. You know, what are some flaws that you've
seen in the way we are taught history and
why it matters?
GORDON-REED: Well, I think one of the things
that we do is to think of it in terms of facts
and dates and things that are kind of set
in stone. And I don't think that people understand
enough or think enough about the fact that
history or historiography, that is writing
about history, is a continuum, continual process
of revision. As you find new facts, as you
ask different questions. So the idea of the
past is something that is fixed and static
is problematic. And I think that may be one
reason that a lot of people or many people
don't begin to appreciate history until they
are older. They think of it as, as I started
out saying, facts and dates and hard, concrete
things that you have to remember and are set
in stone, when it's very fluid. And lots of
things are going on at the same time, it's
like a river. Different currents going different
ways and teasing all of that stuff out, to
me at least, is what makes history fun and
exciting.
SIERRA: Hm. And of course, it changes depending
who's telling that history, right?
GORDON-REED: Absolutely, absolutely. Every,
you know, different people ask different questions.
And certainly, different generations ask different
questions of material. Based upon the things
that are going on around them. Historians,
the thi- if the, the Vietnam war, World War
II. All of these things, you see it in terms
of, of the current, you know, the current
crisis. Whether you even a current crisis,
whether you're sort of acknowledging that
or not, whether you know it or not-it shapes
your world.
SIERRA: So you've probably graded a lot of
papers. What grade would you give, you know,
human society on their, uh, interpretation
and learning from history?
GORDON-REED: History, I don't know. Well-
I don- I'm, I'm a pretty lenient grader, uh,
generally. A B, B minus something like that.
I, I wouldn't fail us.
SIERRA: That's not bad.
GORDON-REED: No, that's not bad. No, it's
not bad. I, I think, I think it depends on
what kind of history. I mean, in, in America,
we focus on, well, there, there's so many
... Well, there's sort of different, different
parts of history. I, I would give ourselves
a B minus. I, I would be generous on that
one.
SIERRA: Well, that's good. I like that one.
I'll take that grade.
GORDON-REED: But, you know, it's really frightening
to me to think of the sort of retrenchment.
People thinking you don't need history classes
and, you know, it's all STEM, STEM, STEM.
Which I think is very, very important, but
for citizenship, for good citizenship, you
need to have an understanding of, of history.
And so, that's the only thing that I, that
concerns me now is the, the sort of marginalizing
this as a soft subject, when it is a critical
subject.
MACMILLAN: History is not just something that
lies there like a great dead matter in the
past. It's something that weaves into our
lives. And, and has created the world in which
we live. And therefore, I think if we want
to know more about our own world, we need
to know the history.
MACMILLAN: I think it can tell us that nothing
bad lasts forever. Although, it may also tell
us that nothing good lasts forever. And I
think it can tell us that, you know, human
beings are enormously resilient. I mean, you
look at what we've come through, and you think
of the ancestors of many of the people in
the United States, what they have suffered,
wherever they came from, whether they were
brought as slaves from Africa, whether they
came as impoverished immigrants from Europe.
And you think of the challenges of living
in this country, certainly, before the modern
age. And people survived and managed. And
I think that sort of comfort is there in history
that we are resilient.
HAASS: That's what's so good about history.
There's, there's parallels which don't necessarily
give you a bottom line in how to understand
something or what to recommend. But they can
sure give you, you know, they can sure give
you guidance. And, again, that's where it's
a tool. It's a, I think there's a, a difference
between being an answer and being a tool.
And history is a tool.
SIERRA: We use history to center ourselves
on a timeline, to evaluate where we’ve been
and where we’re headed. There’s a quote
about all of this that keeps popping up in
my head. It’s from a short story by William
Faulkner. “The past is never dead. It's
not even past.”
It can seem confusing at first, but to me
it captures how if you understand the past
- both your own past and human history - you
can see how it continues to inform everything
that happens around you.
Knowing history is an empowering thing. It’s
a tool for societies - and societies that
understand their histories well tend to make
better decisions. But it’s also a tool for
us, as individual human beings, in our own
lives. Having your own sense of history gives
you agency - it makes it harder for other
people to shape your opinions in malicious
ways, or for someone to tell you that things
have always been the way they are, when they
haven’t.
Decades from now, children will be reading
about these years, and the decisions we make,
in their own history books. Let’s not make
those decisions in the dark.
Be sure to visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters for
show notes and further reading recommendations
for this episode. Want to say hi to the Why
It Matters team? Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you like the show, leave us a review!
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations. The show is created
and produced by Jeremy Sherlick, Asher Ross,
and me, Gabrielle Sierra. Our sound designer
is Markus Zakaria and our summer intern is
Wynne Dieffenbach. Robert McMahon is our Managing
Editor, and Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital
Officer.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off. See you next time!